toxic 373 says reminder Tom Cruise was
right when he scolded Matt Lauer on the
day show about Psychiatry and
antidepressants it actually was right
let's go back because you you mentioned
it
let's go back and remember this was Tom
Cruise back in I think it was like 2004
or five this was this was a while ago it
was over 15 years ago and he had this
conversation with Matt Lauer and on The
Today Show
about Psychiatry and psychiatric
medicine and depression and he has been
mocked ruthlessly for this ever since
but it turns out he was 100 right let's
watch that again
here we are today where I talk out
against drugs
and psychiatric abuses of electric
shocking people okay against their will
of drugging children with them not
knowing the effects of these drugs do
you know what Adderall is do you know
riddlin do you know now that Ritalin is
a street drug
do you understand that the differences
I understand there's abuse of all of
these things now you see here's the
problem you don't know the history of
Psychiatry I do all it does is mask the
problem Matt and if you understand the
history of it it masks the problem
that's what it does
that's all it does
you're not getting to the reason why
there is no such thing as a chemical
imbalance I'm saying that drugs aren't
the answer that these these drugs are
very dangerous they're mind-altering
antipsychotic drugs and there are ways
of doing it without that so that we
don't end up in A Brave New World yes
there are abuses and yes maybe they've
gone too far in certain areas maybe
there are too many kids on Ritalin maybe
electric shocking kids unreal I'm just
saying but but aren't there examples
where it works you don't even you're
glib you don't even know what Ritalin is
if you start talking about chemical
imbalance you have to evaluate and read
the research papers on how they came up
with these theories Matt okay that's
what I've done and you go and you say
where's where's the medical test where's
the blood test that says how much
Ritalin you're supposed to get you're
it's very impressive to listen to you
because clearly you've done the homework
and you know the subject and you should
and you should do that also because just
knowing people who are on Ritalin isn't
enough
that uh he
couldn't be more right about everything
that he said
and what he says there at the end though
well just because you know someone on
this drug and you say it works and
that's that's not enough to declare that
the drugs should be prescribed or that
they work
but that has always been the response
right you what Matt lauers or Matt Lauer
I thought did a very good job of playing
the role of the kind of hapless
uh uninformed person
who has dipped their toe into this issue
and has a lot of has a few anecdotal
stories and then Main and then and then
kind of goes along with the mainstream
narrative because of it he's playing
that role you know uh convincingly
because that's who he actually is and
was it still is presumably
but everything you heard from that
louder in that exchange is like I've
heard the same thing so many times over
the years
you you make all these points you have
data and research about the the
medicines that these the so-called
medicines that the farm Farmers is
giving out
um about the psychiatric industry the
way they go about these these issues
you you have your criticisms that are
well thought out based in research based
in the data and then what you always get
in response is yeah but I know someone
I know someone who felt better with it
and then well it might be over diagnosed
but certainly
and you hand what you just by by saying
by with the acknowledgment that it might
be over diagnosed you hand wave away 65
million people on psychiatric medication
and Tom Cruise again has been mocked for
that ruthlessly ever since he was 100
right
foreign
Tom Cruise is a Scientologist
and as people have pointed out online
over the last day or two
that well this doesn't vindicate Tom
Cruise because he's a Scientologist and
his criticism of Psychiatry are rooted
in in Scientology
and the part that he doesn't say is that
yeah modern Psychiatry is flawed you
shouldn't take these drugs you should be
a Scientologist instead that's the party
doesn't say in the interview but yet but
that's what he means that's where he's
leading to
and you might be right about that in
fact you probably are now whether he is
a Scientologist and yeah okay so you're
right about that
doesn't change the fact that what he
says there is true
and the fact that the kooky crazy
Scientologist
has more insight into this issue and
makes more sense
than most other people talking about it
the fact that the Scientologist makes
more sense than most of the
psychiatrists and big Pharma Executives
on this issue
um that's not embarrassing
for those of us who agree with Tom
Cruise that's embarrassing for the rest
of you
that Tom Cruise is smarter than you on
this on this subject
like if you disagree with Tom Cruise on
that and then and then and Tom Cruise is
Vindicated you you should you should
really look at yourself and and ask
yourself what well how did the
Scientologist get this right and I
didn't
that should be the wake-up call
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really as that's what
it is or Joy we're forming a cult then
all you gotta do is click the Subscribe
button and ring the bell below uh this
video to stay up to date with all my
content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at the
daily wire.com Spotify or apple podcast
looking forward to welcoming you to the
Sweet Baby gang